[Music]
in team effort news
do you remember yeah team efforts just
say team effort again my team and we
make an effort I made an effort you did
see this hair I did too man it's freshly
shaved I did it I just put a cap on I
always do my very best with my hair I
really just never enough dude
Joe's hair pisses me off because look at
this [ __ ] he just mess his hair my hair
look like that if I had a surgeon in
here okay I say have Ken's hair for like
the longest time really that was like
ball for like eight years we could go
and Nikki was like hey Joe did you do
your hair with a balloon this morning
and I was like what must she think about
me you you were balding you could grow
your hair that well yeah I mean I shaved
it cuz I was lazy to do my hair yeah cuz
I think because my hair is so thick it's
difficult to figure out like a haircut
like a style it just does one thing yeah
you you look like a [ __ ] gangster
with like shaved
yeah that's why every time I see you
yeah it's funny cuz when I when I have a
bald head I always got pulled over now
you put over all the time actually were
shooting at my office yesterday and the
police were like we heard it was a
disturbance I was like we heard some rap
music being black in public that's all
we're doing we're loud by nature we're
just loud you guys freestyle rapping we
were armas I didn't want admit to he's
like what do you guys do it is I was
somebody got shot I didn't want to meet
35 year old men where arm wrestling was
destroyed so we had the door when we
were arm wrestling noises like we're
selling drugs in here Bowser said that
I would have said that selling drugs for
tobacco for drug sales know if it's
armwrestling Tulisa submitted by slow
and furious a company has created the
consent condom which requires four hands
to open I saw this [ __ ] what is a
consent oh all four hands have to open
the condom yeah consent but if you got a
rape buddy it's like yo rape buddy
thanks buddy cool oh I don't think
rapists would spend that kind of money
because you can still get free condoms
or just not even use one at all sure but
they're giving these away though oh
really you know like if we're gonna rape
we're gonna use protection when we rape
that's right we have a code I don't know
any responsible rapists okay that's
crazy for it's a four-way I don't know
that just looks like a like you're
trying to open up a Rubik's Cube
together or some [ __ ] how many arguments
are gonna get started over that like no
it's like this much let me do it they
don't just do it like I just go to it's
like an escape room now so this takes
place in Argentina like my mom bought me
a piggy bank thing that you have to it's
like a scape room puzzle box and I was
like [ __ ] man I can't get through this
[ __ ] so I just broke it
[Laughter]
I wouldn't think there's a condom
commercial shall we do this let's do it
baby
you don't be cook they made that box
into a heart shape you know making a
little bit more you know before the box
cutter proof actually yeah big problem
with reh pari in Argentina that they
need to do something like this no so
they're saying that about 40 so 14.5
percent of Argentinian men regularly use
a condom so they're trying to promote
more condom use that doesn't promote
more condom use that's like I can't get
it open
I'm not yeah what they make condoms that
feel dope that'd be sick I agree with
you guys but they're saying here's like
they wanted to add something else that's
really important which is consent and so
more statistics they said that 65
percent of men said that they
occasionally use them and twenty point
five percent said that they've never
used one before so they're just trying
to spread the condom use word
logistically it just doesn't make sense
because it's like if you don't care
about consent anyway you definitely
don't care about it condoms it's I saw
somewhere someone said this is um you're
you're putting a lot of responsibility
on someone who would would rape you
anyway and it doesn't this was still the
person was saying they'd this wouldn't
help prevent rape rapist it would just
get people Minna an alibi like oh yeah I
couldn't have raped her because she yeah
we open this thing together it's not
gonna actually stop you from using it
it's just like oh well here's my you
know get out of jail free card clothes
it's so hard to get somebody to help you
open something like happy moment - right
and if the girls
passed out she's unconscious just take
her hand and make you that's pretty
smart Nikki I had a guy talk to my kids
about sex and consent way early and I I
mean they're like too young but not too
young
how early 12 and 10 we've been talking
about sex you know for a while but we
introduced consent conversations more
and more over the last couple years and
one thing I said is like let's start
with when you get to that age not having
one-night stands cause they're in a
consensual relationship with someone
over a period of time you're like you're
less likely to have a sexual assault
case I would assume you're not I mean if
you're like oh I just meant to might we
were both drunk the chance is that both
of you were into it and I was like if
you're drinking or she's drinking just
have no sense because you're not gonna
be able to even remember what you did
what she did what was said or don't get
piss ass jump because you might wake up
[ __ ] a pillow right no but like what
if there was a girl in the group - what
if it was in our pillow I see what if it
wasn't a girl [ __ ] my friends on
accident I get it my god it's scary to
be Joe no I was like that's why judges
not trinkets I remember being like what
in junior high high school
I'm way too [ __ ] drunk I'm I wake up
in flashes right so it's like one moment
I'm in the bed next moment I'm in the
shower with my mom [ __ ] like watering
me down
the shower hose I'm like a dish you know
she's like [ __ ] man wiping the bar
fall for my [ __ ] chest and everything
they didn't [ __ ] collecting me next
moment I'm I'm [ __ ] pissing in the
trashcan and in the next moment like you
know like I'm packing a pillow huh yeah
I'm cool that's what she told me
nice I was having a romantic time that's
what she told me the next day she was
like you were [ __ ] the living [ __ ]
out of that commercial for consent for
drinking yeah well like what if what if
you know like there's a party right and
then there's just too drunk ass kids and
then they're just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of each other they didn't know and then
they both regret it the next day and
it's like I didn't consent but you were
drunk that's why you shouldn't be
drinking that much yes the commercials
just Joe Sam I pissed in a trash can and
then I walk off [ __ ] my pillow
don't drink yep baby come on you're
gonna miss per name to the air and all
that [ __ ] I don't even remember it's so
good be the girl and then from that
point on is this okay is this okay
is this okay that's what they call it
pillow talk that point my mom wouldn't
stop calling my pillows my girlfriend
there's a character on there that
literally had Jay bells Aryan he always
had sex with his pillow
he's gonna keep down he was bi because
he's like I like the couch pillow but
also my bed pillow that show is insane I
feel so guilty why would she give it
another chance
it is wild though like I feel like super
guilty for watching it but the one
character it's just because they're like
middle school kids and I just feel like
I don't know I just feel weird being an
adult
I mean it's animated so they get away
get away with a whole bunch of stuff
it's all adult people doing the voice
Nick Crowe does like 12 or 13 other
voices watching it but then I stopped
feeling weird because then I put myself
in those shoes where I was like I
remember experiencing oh yeah so then it
kind of removes it yeah
I was so naive middle school I was still
in a Nickelodeon like I was still like I
was just so socially behind like boys
were still gross
wait Nickelodeon wasn't cool middle
school no everyone had boyfriends they
were into making out they were into like
makeup and all this stuff and I was like
but I just wanna watch cartoons I did
both I smoked weed watch cartoons and
then yeah went to parties and all that
stuff I were getting made fun of in
fifth grade because I had an x-man
folder and then now everyone [ __ ]
loves axeman's dude but back then it was
[ __ ] nerdy [ __ ] and everyone's like
you're a [ __ ] nerd dude no I was not
a movie yet I know exactly it was a
Jubilee came out you know oh my god yeah
the Jubilee saga was that one is the
worst x-men okay we can see literally
throws fireworks and sparkles yeah
fireworks are very powerful you ever
[ __ ] let a firework in your hand but
she always brings you two that's high
magneto and signals went dude we're
getting killed you know what fireworks
in my episode was the Jubilee episode
yeah yeah yeah where she discovers I
remember that because everybody was like
oh my god is coming out we gotta watch
it yeah and I was like in Elementary
yeah but magneto hates fireworks to use
think about where magneto grew up dude
from the [ __ ] camps dude he's not
used to joys like that Sophie's my work
he's just like I can't yeah I'm so sad
and he's like how can anyone do
fireworks when the world is so bad yeah
I don't mind gay yeah he doesn't like
joyful no he doesn't like that [ __ ]
I love magneto hey it's Valentine's Day
oh don't watch it now you probably hate
it
it taught me my first love triangle
because like Wolverine love Jean and she
loved him back but she was with Scott
and then Scott was never really the man
for her and then rogue loved Wolverine
but he couldn't be with her and then
gambit little rolled wait what the [ __ ]
you mean Scott was never the man for her
are you kidding me bro are we gonna
fight right now Scott was the man for
trash Cyclops is trash
the leader of the x-men sister
he's like the coach's son leader like oh
yeah you're on the team because they're
the coach's son
you're not the man though it's still the
leader respects the coach's son I
respect this share of the coach's son
Martin my coach's son was cool
he's the hall monitor yes you got a
cyclops
Wolverine habit in Rome really which
one's blue Jayla you know a mystique
I always thought mm-hmm rogue is [ __ ]
hot well you'll never be able to [ __ ]
her unless you wear a latex suit yeah
you should take your powers you touch
her skin then at one time when she
finally kissed I forgot who it was David
gambit yeah she took the [ __ ] gambit
[ __ ] her powers man think about think
about just being married to rogue and
like you just reach over grab a tittie
and then you're oh [ __ ] I forgot you
couldn't you couldn't you couldn't
handle this life was ugly as [ __ ] cuz
then it would like oh cool you know you
don't want to touch her anyway that's
fine dude that should i do - Nikki I
should be [ __ ] reported to the federal
government did cuz I just reach over
grab all the time but if it was rogue
I'd be [ __ ] do you have to that's like
a baby sucking her thumb at night you're
like oh I had a nightmare and you just
yeah even when she's in the throes of
crisis like I just had a shake that I
grab that [ __ ] ass I just do I'm
gonna join the world a better place
exactly sometimes she's like not right
now but then sometimes she's cool with
it
she's so devastated but whatever
happened that's okay I just admit it's
like when we moved in our cat was in the
closet for three days and we could pet
him as much as we wanted because he was
broken inside and usually that cat
doesn't let you pet him
[Music]